la seule façon d'y arriver c'est d'y
croire
alanis obomsawin le gala québec cinéma
va vous remettre le grand prix hommage
iris la semaine prochaine pour
l'ensemble de votre oeuvre et votre
oeuvre ses 52 films sur la réalité des
autochtones
comment vous avez voulu changer le monde
avec tous ces films là je voulais que
dans les classes des enfants apprennent
la belle histoire de notre pays sur nos
peuples parce qu'on avait écrit
d'ailleurs qui avait été écrit par les
frères des écoles chrétiennes
je pense que c'est criminel ce qu'ils
ont fait
parce que
dans ses livres officiellement on
enseigner aux enfants nous autres les
sauvages que ce qu'elle paie les pauvres
blancs tout ce genre de
d'histoire et pour créer ils ont réussi
là un vernis au peuple alors de tout
faire pour nous rendre invisibles ils
ont réussi pendant plusieurs générations
et moi je me suis révolté et je voulais
absolument un changement
de cette attitude envers nos cols c'est
très difficile de refaire les
réalisations dans cette condition là la
police déclare avoir trouvé des armes à
feu parmi vos plus grandes oeuvres vous
avez tiré quatre films de la crise d'oka
raflé 18 pris au passage ici à
l'international comment avez vous trouvé
l'équilibré entre le militantisme et la
colère ça c'est une période qui a été
très dur très difficile
faire ces films là j'étais là
toute la
la résistance de 78 jours et
je dois vous dire que c'était très dur
mais je suis très content d'avoir fait
ces documentaires là pour que les gens
puisque on pense vraiment qu est-ce qu
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vraiment
quelles étaient les raisons pour cette
résistance je pense que ça a été
possible à travers
ces quatre films l'a fait ça fait un
coffret à la fin et
pour encore une fois je pense toujours à
l'éducation pour l'enseignement
c'est historique c'est très important
que les gens sachent la veille
situation pour tous ceux et celles à la
maison qui ne vous connaissent pas s'il
y avait un seul film qu'on devait voir
de vous ce serait lequel
je suis très reconnaissante d'avoir vécu
aussi longtemps pour avoir été capable
de faire le film
il n'a jamais de la guérison
on a filmé 500 enfants métis des
premières nations qui jouait du violon
imaginez vous quelles chances qu'elle se
filment leur jeu mais si je meurs demain
je vais peut-être tu vois la grande
possibilité quand les gens des
communautés mêmes prennent la dirigeante
vous êtes une pionnière parce que vous
vous êtes fait traiter de tous les noms
dans les années 60 mais aujourd'hui
certains vent de changement je pense à
musique nomade wapikoni mobile ou six
est ce que vous sentez ce changement là
un peu quand même
c'est un et les changements sont énormes
sans rien avoir à ce que ces tests de
l'est les dernières dix années surtout
avant à chaque fois que moi j'ai
toujours faire des documentaires mais au
les sauvages sur tout un c'est toujours
mais maintenant c'est autrement je sens
que partout au canada mme même au québec
il ya un oreilles qu'on n'a jamais avant
et que les gens veulent voir une justice
et c'est ça qui est encourageant veut
savoir que finalement
qu'ils comprennent exactement ce qui
s'est passé et connaître la vraie
histoire et voit quelque chose de juste
pour nos peurs on a oublié
qu'est-ce que l'indien lui enseigner lui
au gland et que c'est l'indien qu'il a
bel et bien sauvé de la mort quand les
blancs sont les premiers blancs qui sont
venus ici
en terminant je veux pas trahir votre
âge vous êtes une force de la nature
c'est le travail qui qui vous garde en
forme
oui je me sens bien et je suis chanceux
parce que tu as une bonne santé g 87 ans
je vais travailler jusqu'à ce que
je suis capable pour l'instant savoir je
suis très occupé
beaucoup de travail
et je fais en ce moment encore je puis
dire que j'en ai jamais album sound
merci merci m mois qui vont venir
nous sommes mieux comme